hello and welcome back to New rockstars
I'm Jessica Clemens and this is the no
spoiler review of black panther wakanda
forever I was so honored to be invited
to the Press screening and junk it I got
to ask the cast some fun questions I was
so excited you guys so much so that I
had a panic attack 10 minutes before the
interview ask producer John I'm a mess
regardless new rock stars doesn't do
many reviews but some hot takes have
made their way to the internet already
and we want to share our views hopefully
I can get you all even more excited and
ramped up because I'm no critic and once
black panther work on it forever
actually drops expect an in-depth
breakdown from King Voss himself and
thanks to Rocket money for sponsoring
today's video more about them later
again this will have no spoilers but
just be careful social media and the
comments that follow until you see the
movie because you know how the internet
works it's a mysterious place so my
general thoughts overall I loved it Ryan
coogler will always deliver to me black
panther is one of the most cinematic
movies the MCU delivered on and the
tradition is still kept in wakanda
Forever it's so captivating and will
always keep your attention solely off at
cinematography costume design and
musical score as we all go in morning
Chadwick Boseman men Marvel really spent
a great deal of time and dedication and
Remembrance to the actor and you see it
throughout the movie it perfectly
balances out grief hope and remorse and
yes we've seen this in different Marvel
properties from like technically
Spider-Man Wanda division Thor 11
Thunder but Leticia Wright and Angela
Bassett and the rest of the cast really
invoke every single emotion you face
when losing not only your king but your
beloved co-star at times it doesn't feel
like they're actually acting
representation also really matters you
guys especially for myself as a black
person but I know that goes for the
Latin folks as well so this movie's
cultural significance to brown and black
people are it's so good when I saw the
first black panther I was so happy to
see someone who looked like me in a
position of strength and power and
resilience it's not every day you see a
king protected by a team of black
warrior women I like to learn as much as
possible about history I was an art
history major and it was one of my
favorite parts of Miss Marvel so
learning everything and anything about
Namor was important to me and I think
they did a lot in that allocated time
given this part might be a weird
takeaway truly take it as you will did I
cry not really but did my heart
literally shatter into pieces with me
leaving the theater a shell of a woman
100 absolutely it was really hard for me
to stand at the end overall like
storyline and my feelings towards it
wakanda forever did such a great job
with such a huge and ambitious storyline
we need to remember the timeline this
entire movie had to go through to get to
where it was today according to vulture
they started shooting in June 2020. you
know when kovid was like really hitting
when our boy Chadwick Bozeman passes
away August 28 2020 December 2020 they
went through a bunch of more covet
stipulations August 2021 Latisha Wright
was injured on set November 2021 Marvel
shutdown production the crew went on
Hiatus and January 2022 a lot of the
cast and crew tested positive for covet
you know it just felt like this movie
was never gonna come and it was going
through a lot from having to readjust
the script to covet to injuries so much
was happening behind the scenes and this
movie really pulled through you can see
the hard work put into it every
character has their own story to tell
lives to live and are interchangeable
out of this movie my favorite part is
the character development and
relationships that's why I'm doubling
down on the script overall because the
dialogue and storytelling is just so
smooth the two hours and 41 minutes was
paced perfectly for myself I kept
looking at my watched because I didn't
want it to be over I was like please
please don't stop this it grips you
anxiously in the First Act you guys
perfectly brings you to peace Smothers
you in refinement then in the climax
seizes your confidence but on the
subject of storyline this can be our
segue into how this movie will fit as a
major MCU event so many new characters
and so many new justifications and let
me tell you coogler is clearly a comic
book fan and loves doing some fan
service this movie does tie up some
loose ends in the MCU overall and I
think Ryan coogler meant to do that
coogler is an avid comic book reader so
it's no surprise that he answers what we
theorize about all the time but also
leaves room for interpretation and
inspiration with wakanda forever there's
a minimum of six major plot points that
easily will be pulled across the MCU
phase five and six that's a huge deal
you guys this movie affects the past
present and future and remember this is
the last movie of phase four this was
our gift and farewell package so you'll
get an idea of where the MCU is headed
especially with the knowledge from d23's
MCU timeline but I can guarantee you
won't know everything I don't even know
everything uh no one knows everything as
we know phase four could easily be seen
as what is green if not love persevering
face but as my mom says from ashes come
new life and we should keep that in mind
when transitioning into phase five if
you're wondering like hey Jessica what
should I watch before black panther
wakanda forever it's black panther if
you want to watch more than the first
movie you could watch Infinity war and
end game just for the continuity as some
references are made stick to the first
black panther just to understand
everyone's Dynamic and significance to
wakanda I've gone all in on black
panther wakanda forever and it's so so
good and when Black Friday and Cyber
Monday roll around you know I'm gonna
track down every merch deal on the
internet to deck out my place in
anything black panther because that's
what the holidays are all about and
because I've been using rocket money to
help save money all year I've got the
extra money I need to indulge as much as
I want and you guys no I'm addicted to
merch rocket money is my favorite
all-in-one finance app helps me manage
my expenses and save hundreds so I can
spend more on what matters to me which
right now the life-size cardboard cutout
of shuri looking determined and fierce
so let me tell you about it one of
Rocket money's best features is that it
helps you find and cancel all your
unwanted subscriptions and I know each
and every one of you have at least two
unwanted subscriptions right now I have
six with the app I discovered I was
wasting hundreds thousands every month
on stuff I didn't even use with the
money I saved from canceling those
subscriptions I freed up lots of money
for the inevitable wakanda forever
soundtrack slash Rihanna Arena concerts
I need to see I also really like their
smart savings account and their budget
tool with the smart savings account you
can just choose the amount you want to
save and how frequently rocket money
will automatically deposit your money
into a savings fund that you can
withdraw at any time that is a deal with
the budgeting tool you can automatically
monitor your spending by category get
notifications when you've exceeded your
spending limits and visualize your spend
to earn ratio by month quarter or even
year if you really are feeling ambitious
rocket money can even negotiate your
bills for you from internet service
bills to cable and phone bills simply by
uploading a photo and tapping a button
it's all visual baby you can unlock even
more features in Premium Too once you've
signed up 3.4 million people use rocket
money to save with just a few simple
Taps and you could be one of them if you
want to start managing your finances the
easy way you need this app to try
rocking money out for free and support
our Channel head to rocketmoney.com new
rockstars or click the link in the video
description go ahead and then come back
to the video so I've gone off about my
favorite Parts okay and I have some
quarrels I know the woman that always
disagrees with everyone on every piano
show about something slightly different
has something to say it is kind of funny
because overall none of them are
actually negative at the top of the
review I said I'm no critic which is
very true everyone will have different
opinions on this film like every film
and I'm solely here to share my
experience and thoughts on why you
should be excited like I was every MCU
property has their own story that speaks
to different people I would never say
otherwise if you don't like something
I'm sure someone else does and if you
come out of black panther or condo
forever not liking it okay that's your
feelings but for me I'm gonna turn up
when I say none of my critiques are
negative I mean that they don't make or
break the movie I want them to get into
the history and cultural aspects more I
would love to see the wildlife of
wakanda things that wouldn't make or
break this movie in my opinion I love
the movie because it felt authentic its
message was clear and the representation
was there and spoke so much to me the
title is literally wakanda forever which
has many interpretations but for me it's
the nation is the people the regions and
no one can take that away from them no
matter what so this easily to my final
thoughts the movie was nothing like I
expected the trailer gave us so many
fighting scenes tears farewell homages
but when watching the movie it wasn't
really telling how the storyline would
go every MCU plot point is so heavy and
had me pointing at the screen like
Leonardo DiCaprio's meme the like
yeah you know you know what I'm talking
about so there's a lot to take away as
far as situations that can come up again
in the MCU later but this movie is meant
to conjure feelings and perception I
don't want you to be like mayor Voss or
anyone else that does these breakdowns
and look in every nook and cranny for
Easter eggs but really devour this movie
as a whole I'll be seeing it again
opening tonight for the Easter eggs but
I went into the Press screening wanting
the same feeling when I entered the
first black panther years ago I wanted
to feel what the actors felt and truly
understand every character and
justification the movie is literally
poetic it's beautiful sad joyous all of
the above and I hope you love it I hope
it speaks to you like it did to me I
hope you leave the theater a shell of a
person just like I did opening night
will be wild so please be safe be nice
to the theater workers clean up after
yourself and always remember we gonna be
all right
foreign
[Music]